the Joe Rogan experience you know you
have really fast cars might see that one
right there yeah the one that looks like
a dad that's that one blows all yeah and
you can drive like a companion piece of
[ __ ] cuz it's silent do it no one
notices here so quiet you just passed
people like you just whiz by them yeah
nothing happens yeah a Tesla is the new
BMW in terms of people who are driving
like [ __ ] bags on the way to work
because when it's silent people don't
like call the cops or sneer you're just
kind of gone dude I was at a red light
with some kid in a Model 3 and I was in
my gt3 RS and he blew behind me Liuba I
was even trying to race him cuz I know
better
ya have a Tesla but it was the
humiliation factor he passed me and got
in front of me and then got on the
highway like yeah like it was nothing
sure and he an Evo fast evey if you live
in Los Angeles is the correct tool for
for this job you know if you have a home
or in your case [ __ ] sick warehouse
to keep it charged
you know supercharger networks pretty
good yeah but it's not I wouldn't say
you can use it exclusively you need some
some kind of home rage the charge yeah
or your office but um people who live in
apartment complexes that have Tesla's I
don't know how you do it yeah if you
don't live in a building where you can
get them to install one or you work in a
building yeah something yeah you really
Eevee's are amazing and they're super
super fun and like I totally get why
people like like I get you're evey
evangelism transformation you having
gone from the but that the but the
thought you know analog school of you
know manual gearboxes and [ __ ] loud
to to experience that level of silent
performance and you must have felt like
you're in a [ __ ] spaceship it's seen
it still seems like a spaceship yeah
drive that thing yeah quiet yeah it
makes me feel good though well if you
finally you know you get a little more
relaxed right yeah like it when I take
it to the airport to because I put on
auto and I get on the 405 and I just
chill in traffic it's nice
oh no it's nice it is I totally get it
be careful with it oh I have my hand on
the wheel no no it does be careful
what's saying it drives itself it
doesn't it doesn't drive it so does it
do here the rabbit hole begins it has it
has an advanced drivers aid system mmm
okay so it has follow you know follows a
car in front of you and it has a
pretty good Lane keep assist right so
now we go into the Joe Rogan rabbit hole
of what does driving me so driving
involves decision-making and driving
involves a lot of mental processes that
cars can't do and so that's when I when
people talk about terms like
self-driving cars or full self-driving
or whatever they're not usually using
those terms correctly so a bunch of cars
not just Tesla right now although
Tesla's system is very good have a very
good lane keep assist in a very good
radar cruise system and they have
different methods of trying to ensure
the drivers paying attention but I think
the marketing is a little bit
disingenuous and they really want people
who don't know better to think and feel
like this is a car that drops its kind
of putting it on beta it's all just beta
bro I'm riding my scooter I know I just
had a Model 3 for a week like couple
weeks ago and I liked it so much and I
gave it back and I went God maybe I
should lease one of these this is cool
but the auto steering feature I use it
for about 20 minutes and it scared the
piss out of me twice and I went man
you've seen that company called axis
that takes a Model S and they put a
carbon body of wide body kit onto now
that sounds like fun that's pretty dope
the axis Model S P hundred one hundred D
is they replace the entire body with
carbon they take the hood they take the
fenders off they put wide body fenders
on they they do a bunch of different
[ __ ] to it you know I don't think so I
wouldn't I wouldn't [ __ ] with that
yeah they'd [ __ ] with the suspension
they tighten up the suspension they
changed the wheels and they completely
redo the interior they stripped the
interior that's where I would start
yeah custom interior put put in whatever
you want need
[Applause]